yeah means i'm going to death of him
into a micron of refugees I'm answering
the question alone hotel which is about
basically what I care about here I come
from intend to go I would say that the
central question of my life has been the
parable of the talents I am a pretty
much matter if I had never seen it
hopefully life with education with
excellent family I parented every single
to provide whatever I'm weed and so the
central question I have is how can I put
those talents that we are given to you
be at the service of those that we have
not the same kind of privilege the same
kind of like now I tried in politics and
now i'm trying doing animation work with
refugees that are the most vulnerable
and the most vulnerable integrals and i
believe it's my duty to use everything I
can everything I gained in my life to
try to be moving a little bit on me
that's the life of us the touch will get
the most victimized by the injustice of
today's one